talk to me a little bit about van life
it's like you literally live the van
life like you had to pack all your gear
into a van you guys would sleep in the
van right i mean it is a hard [ __ ] you
have to be young and just full of dreams
i feel like anyone can do it if they
love music that much what was your per
diem a day again i read it was like
seven dollars a day
and you said for seven dollars a day
living in the van you could buy weed
you could buy uh i guess like taco bell
or something for food and uh and what
was the third thing cigarettes like that
was just six like that was it and you
were lucky if you got that you know but
you just found your way listen
but you were being paid
you were being paid to be a musician i
was a professional musician making seven
dollars a day [ __ ] rolling around in
some rust bucket with six other stinky
dudes like you know you're [ __ ] great
dude
but there's such magic in your story
because iggy pop is one of your heroes
you've spent your life listening to iggy
pop you know every song every iggy pop
ever did and you're parked in your van
and some dude comes by and says hey um
you know essentially iggy pop needs a
drummer
come in and play for iggy pop and you go
oh yeah i know his songs and the next
thing you know while you're in scream
iggy pop has you on stage with him and
you're playing but no rehearsal right i
mean barely no we had six hours before
we were gonna play and so i'm just
sitting there waiting and this guy comes
up to the window and he's like
who's the drummer and i'm like oh [ __ ]
what did i do like did i burn down the
club did i [ __ ] would it and he's
like i said me he said you want to play
drums i think he'd pop
and
i walked in there and there was iggy
with a guitar he was performing but he
didn't have a band and he said do you
know my music i said absolutely i sat
down and we started he started playing
like 1969 or something or i want to be
your dog and it was like
it sounded amazing it was just the two
of us
we ran through it and then he started
showing me new songs like what the [ __ ]
is going like what
and then we did a couple of those and he
said okay we're on at six o'clock and i
was like oh you want to do this in front
of people like you wanted to do this and
i said you we need a bass player he's
like you got one and i [ __ ]
went out to the van and got skeeter and
he came in and for that one night
that would to me that was the first time
i ever felt like making it and if it was
the last time i would have been [ __ ]
good because not only was i jamming with
iggy
but like record company people they
thought we were his band so they were
coming up like can we get you anything
right and i realized like oh my god i
could have anything i [ __ ] want right
now and two hours later it was over i
was back in the [ __ ] van with my
stinky friends in the [ __ ] sleeping
bag and i talk about this in the book a
little bit it's not having a safety net
like when you when you sleep like when
rick astley came up and jammed with us
in [ __ ] tokyo we never met the dude
and we just learned the song an hour
before and i see him on the side of the
stage i'm like hey we just learned your
song it kind of sounds like smells like
teen spirit do you want to come sing in
front of 50 000 people right now he was
like abso [ __ ] lutely and i'm like
rick astley has balls the size of
[ __ ] hippity hops i was like oh my
god because that is a professional
musician you should be able to play at a
moment's notice and and that separates
the men from the boys yes
you